welcome to the 2017 Simon Initiative
Distinguished Lecture series
I'm Richard shyness the Dean of the
Dietrich College of Humanities and
Social Sciences and the faculty lead of
the Simon initiative so thank you all
for coming
for what I'm sure is going to be a
fascinating discussion on scientist
power and the power of scientists by
jean-pierre bourguignon and first let me
say that we are all here today because
of president suresh who about three
years ago created the signing initiative
to translate the immense and excellent
research we do on learning sciences into
better learning outcomes both here at
CMU and everywhere else in the world the
initiative is named after herb Simon our
Nobel laureate who prodded us to take
learning seriously and to do so by
combining the research and educational
missions of the university we are
attempting to convert our entire
educational system at Carnegie Mellon
into a large learning research lab that
supports data driven continuous
educational improvement herb would have
been proud and he would certainly be
delighted to participate in the
initiative the initiative could not
thrive at CMU without the relentless
support of dr. Amy Burkhart CMU is vice
provost for education and now a co-lead
on the Simon initiative Amy is going to
introduce our speaker so please join me
in welcoming Amy
[Applause]
thank you Richard I too would like to
extend my warm welcome to this Simon
initiative Distinguished Lecture series
I do want to also say that as Richard
mentioned I'm delighted to formally join
the leadership team of the Simon
initiative it has been very productive
over the short term that it has been in
existence for example this year I'll
just give you some updates I'm led by a
CMU PhD student Justin Weinberg the
educational technology company 101
placed first at South by Southwest
student start-up madness competition in
March and earlier this month won inks
coolest college startups we also sent a
number of students from our masters of
educational technology and applied
learning science our metals program to
the south by southwest competition I
also will say anyone who's traveling
along Forbes Avenue will see the great
progress of the Tepper building and in
that building will be the home to a new
technology enhanced learning center
which will really be part of the
implementation and realization of that
vision that Richard was talking about
where we're really taking research
translating it into our practice using
that data to then inform iterative
improvement so we're really excited with
every layer of cement and those balloon
bubbles that are part of that structure
we're really excited I will also say
that this summer we will have the third
global learning councils educational
summit and it will be held in Berlin
Germany with a broad cross sector
engagement focusing on the ideas of what
are the core skill sets of the future
and what are the future issues that we
need to address and prepare for in
translating educational research and
impact some core themes are the barriers
to adoption of Technology enhanced
learning methods and tools and also
cross cultural context Intel those are
both seams
that are moving forward as was mentioned
president suresh launched the Simon
initiative four years ago to harness
that cross-disciplinary learning
engineering ecosystem and our goal is to
improve measureable student learning on
our campus and beyond the Simon lecture
series was created to hear
thought-provoking scholars and thought
leaders in this field and today's
speaker certainly continues that
tradition as president of the European
Research Council jean-pierre bourguignon
oversees the European Union's main
funding agency for basic research for
nearly 20 years
jean-pierre served as director of
France's Institute of advanced
scientific studies the international
research institute located near Paris
that was built as the European
counterpart of the Institute for
Advanced Study in Princeton a
mathematician by training and I
understand that the math department has
already engaged him earlier today
specializing in differential geometry
and mathematical aspects of theoretical
physics he has been a fellow of France's
Scientific Research National Centre a
professor at the National Polytechnic
School president of the mathematical
Society of France and resident of the
European mathematical Society he's a
former member of the board of the Euro
Science organization and served on euro
Science open forum committees he is a
foreign member of the Royal Spanish
Academy of Sciences an honorary member
of the London mathematical society and
has been the secretary of the
mathematics section of the academia euro
Pia please join me in giving an
enthusiastic carnegie-mellon welcome to
dr. jean-pierre bourguignon
[Applause]
thank you very much for this very nice
introduction distinguished guests ladies
and gentlemen I'm very honored by your
invitation to give a lecture in this
prestigious lecture series and grateful
to president subra Suresh for his kind
invitation and hospitality for European
Commissioner Carlos murders and myself
this visit has been a great opportunity
to meet a number of people working at
Carnegie Mellon University and to
witness their remarkable achievements in
the number of areas the topic I would
like to address today is not a new one
but it has become more topical in the
last century and then the present one in
several context some truly dramatic some
less so this gives me an opportunity to
reflect on the community I belong to the
scientific community and its relation
with society at large around an issue
that has always occupied humans since
the ancient times namely power indeed
the issue of the relation of
intellectuals in ancient times
intellectual work all philosophers today
one would tend to say scientist and this
is that entomology I will use here to
the rulers has drawn attention in many
historical context one can find
thoughtful contributions on this matter
from many different authors in the
course of history Plateau discusses it
explicitly in book 5 of the Republic a
reference in human thinking written some
2500 years ago in a dialogue between
Socrates and Glaucon here is what Plato
wrote and less said I either
philosophers become kings in our states
all those whom we now call our kings and
rulers take to the push
of philosophy seriously and adequately
and there is a conjunction of these two
things political power and philosophical
intelligence while the Merkley Horde of
the nature who at present pursue either
apart from the other a compulsory
excluded there can be no cessation of
troubles they are open for estates nor I
fancy for the human being race either in
the same dialogue Socrates defines
philosophers are those for whom the
truth is the spectacle of which they are
enamoured today discussing this relation
has become a particular relevance all
the more so as other stakeholders than
politicians have to be taken into
consideration on top of that now the
scientific community has grown
considerably and enjoys a very
remarkable diversity in its internal
organization and practice of science I
will discuss this issue in three parts
looking back at the process of the
formation of a scientific community what
is it today what are the forms of power
scientists have been and are confronted
with in which way do scientists exert
some form of power in a conclusive part
of this lecture I would like to try and
draw some perspectives and what can be
the power scientists in the future and
suggest some conditions for this to
actually happen in the first part of
this lecture let me try and address the
question of how did the scientific
community got organized and what it is
today
to avoid any misunderstanding I will use
the concept scientist meaning persons
with develop or have developed
activities which are akin to what he now
referred to as research through
Whiting's teaching and exchanges i must
recognize that using just one name
is a bit abusive but using different
names could mean make the discussion
confusing and difficult to follow
it might also stress that they take
science as a general term from the
physical sciences engineering and the
life sciences but also the social
scientists and humanities let me start
with one example of the role of this
community in the building and
dissemination of knowledge I could have
taken several others from other cultures
partly because I I will come back to it
later
rumors of Copernicus heliocentric theory
certainly a turning point in human
history reached educated people all over
Europe by a collective effort later at
the time of the Enlightenment a
transnational community of brilliant
thinkers known as the Republic of
Letters freely circulated and
distributed ideas and writings given
even more evidence to that the
development of science by engaged
individuals has always been collective
public and course border the weight
sophistication and complexity of the
scientific enterprise have grown over
the centuries research has become one of
the cornerstones of a higher education
and fundamental to the development of
Industry this led to a considerable
growth of the scientific community at
large in the public and private sectors
what is the present size of this
community that grew from the small
network of the Republic of Letters
giving such an estimate is not that easy
but based on the knowledge of the
figures in some anti-seize such that the
US and the European Union one can
actually each one having about
one-quarter of the total number of
scientists one can estimate that there
are around 7 million people in the
public sector when an estimate shows
that over 50 million people are employed
in the private sector occupying jobs
requiring a science engineering degree
note that the first figure is evolving
very quickly in some countries like
China with its very ambitious program to
develop its higher education and
research sector well therefore talking
about the community of roughly 60
million people at the world level
typically 1% of the world population
what is also quite remarkable today is
the considerable diversity of the
organization of the scientific community
depending on the discipline and on
institutional context in which the
research is conducted the size of
research teams vary from a very small
number even researchers working alone
may have very significant contribution
in some cases I'm talking as a
mathematician to very large groups
sometimes distributed over several
countries as exemplified by the teams
who supervise the critical experiment on
the Higgs boson at CERN in Geneva or who
worked on the detection of gravitational
waves in LIGO and also Virgo this
diversity often refers to the different
types of experimental tools used some
requiring massive investments and long
term planning and highly sophistic
sophisticated technological tools
another element of diversity has to do
with who has the initiative and the
capacity to trigger the research using
the top-down approach or a bottom-up one
is also worth pointing to the importance
scientist always placed in the cementing
disseminating their results from this
point of view in the course of history
several technological inventions played
a critical role printing was first
developed in China more than 2,000 years
ago but was greatly enhanced by the
invention and paper in the earlier early
second century in the 8th century it
spread to the Islamic world and took off
in the Western world with Gianna's
Gutenberg in the 15th century
we should note that motivation the
motivation coming from the need to
disseminate religious texts in the
development of this technical was
enormous of course a new dimension has
appeared with a quick propagation less
than two decades of the internet at
world level it is to be noted that its
mayor invention has been fantastically
triggered by the needs of the scientific
community around CERN coupled of course
with a new computing capacity made
available very broadly and that usually
decreasing prices thanks to the
development of mini
miniaturized chips this opens of course
a totally new era with many new aspects
that have not yet been I'm afraid fully
understood at the part of scientists in
many different countries huge efforts
have gone into producing comprehensive
compendium of up-to-date knowledge as a
Frenchman I'm keen to point to the
extraordinary achievement represented by
the production of the encyclopedia was
also called dictionaries only this yawns
desire ed amici under the leadership of
Danny little my hero and Jean Rohan
Dalembert an extraordinary ambitious
Enterprise whose production started as
an enormous translation effort for
almost 20 years then spent over 20 years
in the second part of the 18th century a
remarkable achievement of Lia lighten
meant which mobilised many authors and
contributors the numerous blades you
find in the answer could be d are a pure
delight it had to face a number of legal
challenges by the political and
religious establishments of the time and
its publication was forbidden a few
times today in the age of the internet
we see similar efforts but the question
of quality control has become partly
because of the breadth of the effort a
much more challenging task we will come
back later in this lecture to this issue
which is paramount when discussing the
relation of scientist with society at
large after having acknowledged
remarkable expansion of the community of
scientists
but also it's huge diversity can really
speak of the a scientific community the
only reason why this possibility really
exists is that over the years scientists
have developed some common rules and
share a good number of values one can
indeed speak of a scientific method
which has been built over centuries and
with respect conditions the validity of
scientific results so the latency by a
French leading astronomer and a dear
friend of mine phrased it beautifully
the scientific method is based on the
twin pillars of observation and theory
observing the world without interpreting
it is of no great interest imagining the
world as we would like it to be without
subjecting it to observation and without
taking account of the real world is
dangerous the very basis of the
scientific method as in the search for
causes of effort effect following the
fundamental principle that every effect
has a cause and they need to aim for a
universality indeed the progress of our
understanding of the way the world
functions has shown that what happens on
earth and in the sky follows the same
rules the key is of course that such an
approach leads to a virtuous circle
cooking on the bike one more time to
understand the scientific methods one
has to realize that progress comes from
a continuous process of calling into
question proposition is only scientific
if it is functions viable in other words
if any one can verify it or invalidate
it this is I'm continuing this is why
the history of scientific ideas is an
excellent school of doubt humility
rigour honesty and the quickl spirit
which are primed virtues in the service
of a passion for knowledge and of course
it is important to stress here that the
two fast
are intimately related to make the
invisible visible
indeed to anyone the earth appears flat
but now it is evident that it is not so
as we can see it any time we fly in the
same way all the intellectual
construction that went into the
development of quantum physics was
provoked by the fact that some
experiment didn't match the theoretical
predictions to make the new physics
tangible when had to develop new tools
to reach a very small scales and
intricate combination of theoretical and
practical knowledge the same applies to
the knowledge one has to now gain from
the universal from the universe getting
observation tools outside the atmosphere
was essential one should never forget
the defeat of detecting gravitational
ways relies on the fact one could detect
a signal with a very definite chain
which is about 1,000 times smaller than
the signal actually recorded this could
only be done through two achievements in
which mathematics plays a crucial role
developing precise models of the merging
of two black holes and using the
completely new tool of wavelets to do a
multi scale analysis of signals with the
precision never accomplished before more
should be said on the extraordinary step
forward made through the change of
riding in biology with the discovery of
DNA double helix and the new world which
could be unraveled thanks to the setting
up the setting of which which there was
not much evidence
therefore the edifice of science has two
phases the regularly revisited process
of the scientific method leading to a
body of knowledge that gets enriched on
the permanent basis and consists of
concepts derived from theories nurtured
by data collected through experiments
note that if the teaching of scientific
facts can require a certain level of
sophistication to grasp the concept
exposure to the scientific method can
start at the very early age in school
and be put to test right away
a very important step which the school
to often miss coming back to the process
of disseminating results the constant
concern of scientist as I mentioned
before the elaborate rules put in place
by scientists to publish the centric
journals remarkably reflect their need
to validate what they disseminate using
peer-review to improve the content made
available of course the new electronic
means of dissemination represents
fantastic new opportunities but also
challenges has all of a sudden it
becomes possible to access in a
searchable form and to compare input
from many different sources
simultaneously
this increases the temptation of the
jerusem and the capacity to fight it
it is astonishing how much has been
accomplished with the understanding
broad by scientists mostly through the
democratization of informed practices
and technical object and a high level of
education in a larger part of the
population we are now richer and live
longer than any other time in human
history Xin 1800 the now rich countries
got anywhere from 18 to 30 times better
off and we are adding to the list of
rich countries each year in 1843 percent
of the world's newborns died before
their fifth birth
in 1960 child mortality was still 18.5%
globally in 2015
China mortality had dropped to 4.3
percent ten times lower than two
centuries ago and child mortality
children under five in rich countries
today is much lower than 1% since 1900
the global average life expectancy as
small and doubled and is now approaching
70 years no country in the world as a
lower life expectancy than the countries
with the highest lie-detection T in the
1800 this shows that without when
scientific knowledge is put to a
positive use so widely spreading shared
standards it impact on improving the
quality of human lives can be massive we
also know though that it has been used
in less positive ways and I will
contemplate some more problematic cases
later in this lecture let me now turn to
the second part of this lecture and talk
about power in order to discuss the
issue of our adequately when asked to
take into account the various interfaces
the scientific community has to engage
with within the corporate world the
political world civil society or
individual citizens of course the most
obvious form of power is the political
one this was the one Sokratis was
mentioning in the quote from Plato I
made in the opening of this lecture over
the century over the centuries the
political power has taken many forms
from the most democratic ones with a
number of counter powers in place
ensuring that the diversity of opinions
is respected and decisions are informed
to the most absolute ones where the will
of the ruler King Emperor dictator or
despots doesn't suffer any contradiction
no limitation political power is an
explicit form of power that has sex most
people in a given society in the course
of history
there are numerous example of saintly
who had to suffer from the austerity of
absolute rulers for their declarations
or in some cases just merely for what
they represented from that point of view
the most extreme case is probably the
prosecution mathematician suffered in
China during the Ming Dynasty which led
to the description of numerous very
valuable pieces of knowledge and the set
back of the discipline in which Chinese
had been prominently productive over
centuries I will come back to some more
specific individual examples in a third
part of the lecture the power that
religious authorities exert in some
society sometimes in direct associations
with the political power some of the
times in their own environment can be as
explicit developing new knowledge can
challenge viewed as central to the
strength of the religion by the clergy
there are some notorious example of such
conflicting cases in history so that's
the fact that Giordano Bruno was burned
by the Inquisition the church judiciary
branch in 1604 his claims galileo
galilei was also prosecuted by the
Inquisition because he propagated
Copernicus discovery that the earth was
not at the center of the universe but
gravitating around the Sun this claim
was considered I quote foolish and
observed in philosophy and formerly
theoretical since it explicitly
contradicts in many places the sense of
all these scriptures he had not to
renounce his view publicly but still had
to leave and to live under house arrest
it would be a mistake to believe that
these obvious forms of power are the
only ones to be considered here some
other forms are more implicit if not
insidious and in recent years they have
been they have been a number of
situations where there were what was at
stake it is a fact that some actors
prefer the shadow to act and can take a
lot of efforts to uncover the maneuvers
by which some action is performed the
economic sector is a definitely powerful
sector whose activity can be affected by
some scientific findings it can activate
several different modes of action from
supporting people to challenge the
findings they consider offensive to
their business this has been witnessed
in number of cases example given the
context of the damage to human health
provoked by smoking to more direct
attitude at attacks on people who
produce the knowledge often through
complacent media and this brings me to
another power namely the press and the
media in general today of course one
cannot forget about the impact that
social media have one they involve a
wide range of people with many different
backgrounds who express themselves
quickly given the often to phonetic
exchanges which are sometimes difficult
to get control over actually there is
one more power it would be inappropriate
to forget about namely the article power
scientists themselves are inserted in
the system that has to make decisions
about people earlier I mentioned the
peer-review system that decides which
articles are published and more
precisely when an article is ready to be
published after possible revisions a
typical situation where the article
power is exerted is at the time of a
promotion or a nomination I would like
to give you an anecdote to show to show
you that even at the highest level of
science there can be situations where
decisions which should be obvious
finally happened because of
considerations which are somewhat
specific to scientists the document I
want to report about was written on June
13th 1913 in Berlin it bears the
signature of max Plante vultan Ernst
Heinrich woman's a mill var world all
distinguished German scientists
physicists actually it contains an offer
of an ordinary member of the membership
of the Prussian Academy with a full
salary to Albert Einstein then
ordinarius in theoretical physics at the
eth in zero
the statement that accompanies the offer
says what should not take too much
against him that it happened to him to
go too far in these speculations example
given in his hypothesis of a quantum of
light without taking some risk one
cannot expect any real renovation also
in the most exact natural sciences the
text written eight years after the
annuals mirabilis 1905 in which Einstein
made three major breakthroughs including
understanding the photoelectric effect
by introducing light quanta shows that
the major discovery can be missed by
great physicists for eight years
fortunately the acceptance of risks
maybe's nomination in the end defendable
now concerning the relation of power by
other stakeholders there are there are
three key questions how is the path
power controlled how is the power
influenced who is advising the power
answering this question in some depth
would take not just a lecture with the
whole course as they touch so many
aspects of the organization of society
and cannot be discussed without being
specific still some general remarks to
prepare for the next stage of the
lecture where I try and discuss some
specific situations in which scientists
are confronted with power and some
others where scientists do exert some
power not necessarily for the good in
the democratic environment the first in
second questions are typically dealt
with through the separation of power the
executive legislative and the judiciary
branches have to be independent from one
another to limit the possibility of
manipulations by the executive branch
actually from one country to the next
the reality of the separation of powers
vary quite a bit with regular attempts
to overrule it in one way or another in
the context of this lecture the third
question concerning scientific advice
has a particular resonance because
especially in our modern societies and
of issues at the scientific bearing on
top of economical and technological
dimensions
moreover some questions are complex
enough to require in-depth knowledge and
understanding of the underpinnings
different countries have adopted
different systems to deal with
scientific advice I'm particularly
interesting in seeing how the science
advice mechanism put in place by
Commissioner Morris to advise the
European Commission and scientific
issues will be performing it consists of
a group of seven scientists nominated by
a body independent from the European
Commission with the power of taking up
some issues by themselves it is
supported by a technical team provided
by the Commission and the cooperation
between European academies moving now to
the third stage or third part of my
lecture I think it is appropriate to
consider a few examples of situations
where the relations of scientists to
power led to effects visible to the
public or actual achievements a new
dimension which now affects one can
approach the problem is the is the
important it's not dominant role
communication media play in the hands of
professionals as well as by society at
large to social media I will come back
to this when summing up my lecture
dramatic example of the misuse of the
fact that the scientists are expected to
to speak the truth took place in October
1914 a critical year in history if any
and 4th October 1914 93 prominent German
scientists scholars and artists
including the physicist Max Planck and
the mathematician Felix Klein issued the
proclamation now known as the manifesto
of the 93 it was originally titled
manifesto to the civilised world it was
a protest against what the writers felt
were the lies spreading about Germany's
role in starting the war to its reasons
for trespassing neutral Belgium and the
denounce brutality of the actions of
these troops there
its purpose was to increase support for
the war throughout German schools and
universities and to win a morale and
morale war the intervention was clearly
meant to be a manifestation of people
who are trustworthy in their relation to
truth here are two excerpts the iron
mouth of events has proved the untruth
of the fictitious German defeats
consequently misrepresentation and
calumny are all the more eagerly at work
as heralds of truth we froze our voices
against these second part of the quote
we cannot rest the poisonous weapon the
lie out of the hands of our enemies all
we can do is to proclaim to the whole
world
our enemies are given false witness
against us you you know us you know us
we with us have protected the most holy
possessions of man we call to you have
faith in us believe that we shall carry
on this war to the end as a civilized
nation to whom the legacy of a girder
Abbott oven and account is just as
sacred as its own earth and homes even
more interesting is a fact which is
little known namely that one of the
signatories will end first term soon
grew to regret having signed the
document and he along with the physicist
gay walk free - nikolai drew up an
inserted - toe to the europeans only
otto buck and Alfred Einstein agreed to
sign it and it remained unpublished at
the time but it was subsequently brought
to light by Einstein I would like to
read read some of this second manifesto
to you now because it is amazingly
humane and pre-signed document so it was
really also in the nineteenth 14 as I
said we wish merely to emphasize as a
matter of principle that were firmly
convinced that the time has come where
Europe must act as one in order to
protect soil or need independence and
our culture
we believe that the will to do this is
latent ly present in many in expressing
this will collectively we hope that it
Ganz's force to this end it seems for
the time being necessary that all those
who hold European civilization there in
other words those who in Goethe's
precise words can be called good
Europeans drawing together at all we
must not give give up the hope that the
collective voice even in the dream of
arms will not trail off entirely unheard
especially if among these good Europeans
of tomorrow we find all those who enjoy
esteem and authority among the educated
peers first it is necessary however that
Europeans get together and if as we hope
enough Europeans in Europe can be found
that is to say people for whom Europe is
not merely a geographical concept but
rather a worthy object of a section then
we should try to call together a union
of Europeans such a union shall then
speak and decide can you imagine that
this was written at the moment the first
world war was giving momentum was
gaining momentum and not in some neutral
country but in Berlin that is in the
heart of Germany one of the key
combatants and it is not is not it
wonderful that we have lived to see
their dream come true and not only did
we see the dream come true but we have
also been able to see it grow and
flourished for over 60 years another
instance were scientist interfere
negatively with the political power has
been the period of domination of Soviet
biology by trolling leasing Co and every
cultural expert is started through
experiments he made on plants and came
to challenge the Mendelian theory
concerning cross fertilization his
results were challenged but what gaining
respect and power was the support he got
from Joseph Stalin which he reinforced
by denouncing the previous theories as
bourgeois and claiming it as politic is
as Paulo tallien although under the
second world war it was more and more
challenged by scientists
also in the Soviet Union he managed to
retain power until the early 1960s this
is an instance where scientists himself
used is relation to the political power
to gain control over the development of
a scientific community of course this
happened in the peculiar political
organization of society which made this
possible
I think I will have to skip some things
I wanted to say I would like I would
like to continue with less dramatic
instances of interactions between before
concluding with another potentially
dramatic one they all have to do with
science diplomacy a role that scientists
play bringing together people from
conflicting countries or communities
let's start with the example of the San
Tropez and our chef nuclear CERN that
was created to develop the collaboration
and research on elementary particles at
the European level indispensable to
reach a critical mass to build an
accelerator able to bring radically new
knowledge
initially it was also a tool to
reintroduce German scientists in the
concert of science after the Second
World War it has grown into a truly
international Enterprise hosting
scientists from many different countries
in particular countries having very
tense relation another example at a
smaller scale but still a seemingly
significant one is the construction of
the sesame synchrotron in Jordan this
project involves scientists from all
neighboring countries including Israel
hence a truly exceptional instance of
collaboration when the relation between
these countries and the circulation of
people between them are very problematic
after these two examples bringing
scientists from different countries
together I will end this brief
exploration of science diplomacy by
considering it from another point of
view namely one that requires that all
countries collaborate around an issue
which has become politically very hot
climate change became evident at the
turn of this century the years to come
it will be a challenge for all societies
to fate it to face its consequence
to give a view on them has been a
challenge also for the scientific
community in a sense accumulating enough
measurements to establish the reality of
the phenomenon required some work and
new level of coordination between
various national actors but no radical
centric breakthroughs and no new type of
engagement from scientists were needed
in order to come up with some
suggestions to control the process
further but better understanding of the
causes within expensable in particular
to determine whether the development of
human activities was at the heart of the
matter this requires much more in-depth
scientific work and the development of
models of another order of complexity it
was a remarkable move by the United
Nations to set up the International
Panel on Climate Change IPCC in order to
bring up a much higher level of
cooperation as thematic collection of
data with a critical look the key
achievement by the IPCC has been to
propose some scenarios for the future of
climate change in 20 to 30 years
depending on the effective measures
taken in the meantime at world level
this very hard work was indispensable in
view of the gravity of the possible
consequences
actually this was making a new type of
request and the scientists involved in
the process and giving them a new form
of power all this will become a reality
only if the political issue nor accepts
in some sense to share the power the
most difficult part of the work is to
obtain that the different governments
actually implement the measures requests
requested over significant length of
time let me close this part of the
lecture by recalling the success of the
European root scientific community
namely the creation in 2007 the European
Research Council that has the honor to
serve as president that was the result
of a long struggle by the scientific
community to overcome a number of
obstacles over a period of more than 10
years this could only be achieved after
the initial request was endorsed by a
number of politicians in particular Jose
Manuel Gago then the protein's Minister
for science and Philippe brusque and
then you
in commissioner in charge of science and
also a key person in the European also
key persons in the European Commission
is required creating some lobbying power
through two organizations euro science a
grassroot organization of scientists and
the initiative for science in Europe
which acted as a common platform for
learned societies scientific
organization and academies as we have
seen the power of scientist can take
more many forms some collectively
beneficiary some others much less so in
recent years at the moment in this tree
of mankind with societal challenges
induced by new possibilities coming from
the centric community have reached an
intensity that they never had before in
such a short period of time
the question of the power of scientist
is is raised more broadly in the society
the quick widening of the use of social
media a first to ordinary citizens a new
platform to formulate the interrogation
and even their reaction is the
scientific community armed to face a
challenge of a new dimension let me now
come to my conclusive remarks after
taking into account is new and wider
context we can try and to draw some
lessons from the examples presented
above looking for a consistent way to
deal with such situations in particular
when they lead to conflicting problems
between scientists and a form of power
they are confronted with I see three
dimensions that need to be to be
addressed some are internal to the
scientific community
some others concerned the whole society
the first one has to do with education
the key in many respects to a healthy
humanity as I pointed out earlier the
cornerstone on which the scientific
community is built is the respect of the
scientific method and the next
generation has to be exposed to it as
early as possible in school this is
probably the only way scientific
knowledge can be acquired with the
appropriate level of depth through
personal experience and confrontation
with the steps required to give to give
it a solid foundation education must
leave enough room
critical thinking based on checking
facts something that the widespread use
of internet by young people does not
provide spontaneously unless they are
properly alerted to the possible abuses
it makes possible in order for this to
happen when needs properly trained
teachers and a permanent contact of the
scientific community with their
community this is exactly what the Simon
initiative is trying to do at a higher
level
this familiarity is key for the power of
scientists to have a wide enough basis
and for it to be rooted in the
experience of knowledge in school of
course this will be effective only if
every child and as a matter of fact any
adult as access as access to quality
education the second has to do with the
importance to be given by scientists to
the ethical side of their activities
they can only happen if students are
exposed this aspect of the research
activity early enough and if suspicious
attitudes on this point of view of
quickly and adequately dealt dealt with
by the sensory community in the
scientific world there is no room for
improper behaviors and scientists should
not be shy about going to the roots of
problems of this nature if they are
proven to be real the question of
Independence of scientists from private
interest in particular in the context of
privately funding research is of
fundamental importance this stresses how
critical it is that sufficient funding
be coming from a priori neutral sources
either public or philanthropic with no
strings attached scientist scientists
cannot too much cannot have too much of
their work dependent from sources having
a vested interest in the result of their
research the third and final one has to
do with the overall relations of
scientists with society at large I
mentioned earlier that the new media
present a new challenge for scientist in
that they offer a new interface between
them at the general public of course
doesn't have only a negative side as it
offers a new space for common ground'
this is often referred to as open
science as indeed there are some domains
where the direct involvement of
interested citizens impacts positively
the development of
science and the part of scientist is
requires an open mind and efforts to
organize this view type of interface if
develop properly this can create a much
broader group of ambassadors but also
for scientists to have a better
understanding what it takes to address
the general public even if these
concerned citizens represent a special
group because of their high level of
motivation let me close by quoting once
more a statement Dame made by Albert
Einstein this time in the fall of 1920
that is almost a century ago I hope you
will share my bewilderment of the
relevance of these words today here is
the quote in my opinion the most
valuable contribution of intellectuals
to international reconciliation and to
the lasting for eternity of man lies in
their scientific and artistic creations
because these elevate the human spirit
above personal and selfishness analytics
aims concentrating energy on questions
and goals that unites all intellectuals
quite naturally generates a feeling of
camaraderie which most inevitably bring
together true scholars and artists of
all countries though it is unavoidable
that less unanimous and less independent
among them will from time to time as a
result of political and other passions
fall out with one another finally I
believe that international
reconciliation would be advanced if
young students and artists in greater
numbers than before were to study in
former enemy countries direct experience
most effectively counteract those
disastrous ideology which under the
influence of the world world war have
been planned planted in many herds any
ha any head scientist should not view
themselves only as specialists but their
citizens conscious that the value they
end up in their profession nearly the
respect for truth the value of exchange
the necessity to doubt and to challenge
must be shared with all the other
citizens this is key in winning their
struggle with power in its different
forms they should not be shy to speak to
speak up their mind it seems that this
is precisely what many
them and also many simple citizens with
many citizens such as Carlos Reuters
have decided to do by joining the
marches for the sides next Saturday I
quote him here I'm quoting Carlos Moyes
I'm really proud that the call for the
martial science resonated in so many
countries that the march is organized in
my home country portable about 480
marches are planned for now on April
22nd it shows the broad support across
the globe for research in science
science is not a dispensable luxury we
need science for the Advancement of our
societies and inform our education
improve our policies and spur innovation
science as a common good also helps all
of us to make sense of sense of and
navigate the more and more complex world
we live in
so when special-interest threatened
scientific evidence and long term
research and when access to and
diffusion of scientists hampered we have
to stand up in support of the scientific
community you will join the March in
Lisbon as a citizen showing an
interesting example of interaction
between power and the scientist I will
be marching in Paris as a scientist
thank you for your attention
you